hi and welcome to Metta fide in this
video we will talk about the cell cycle
and mitosis before starting with the
topic I would like to announce that we
are launching the med simplified
merchandise store on T spring comm
support met simplified and get your
favorite colors and designs on t-shirts
mugs phone cases and much more visit the
link in the description to check it out
billions of cells die in the human body
every day to make up for this our body
produces billions of new ones these
cells are made from already existing
cells most of the cells of our body
divide except a few ones like the cells
present in your heart the cells present
in your muscles and the cells present in
your brain these are known as permanent
cells leaving them aside if we talk
about the rest of the body cells they
can be categorized into two types stable
cells and labile cells labile cells
include cells which are constantly
dividing like that present in our GI T
like mouth in the signs etc stable cells
don't divide all the time but when
required they can like a liver region
rates when half of it is surgically
removed for organ donation so liver
cells or hepatocytes are good example of
stable cells so now let's look at how
these cells divide by the process known
as cell cycle the cell cycle is a
circular pathway in which the cell grows
copies its genetic material and splits
into two daughter cells these daughter
cells undergo the same cell cycle to
produce more new cells now if we look at
the cell cycle it can basically divide
it into two phases the interphase during
which the cell prepares for division and
the mitotic or the M phase during which
the cell actually divides now of course
things in our body cannot be so simple
so these two phases are further divided
into many phases the interface is
divided into three phases g1 s and g2
phase and the M phase is divided into
two known as the mitosis
also known as karyokinesis and the
second phase the cytokinesis as we go
deep into the topic you will understand
storms and the meaning in detail and
before we talk about these phases in
detail I want to clear one important
topic that most of the students get
confused between the term mitosis and
cell cycle and use them interchangeably
but they are different now let me help
you explain this vision example so here
is a cell first it gains nutrition and
grows then it divides its nucleus and
after that it also divides its cytoplasm
to produce two new cells these two cells
continue with the same process to
produce four more cells and so on so if
you look here from this point to this
point this whole thing is known as cell
cycle and the step here during which the
cell divides its nucleus this is known
as mitosis so mitosis is actually a part
of cell cycle during which the nucleus
of the cell divides I hope I am able to
make you understand this clearly now
let's come back to the phases of a cell
cycle in detail and first coming to the
interphase the cell spends its maximum
time in interphase during this phase the
cell obtains nutrients and metabolizes
them grows in size and duplicates its
DNA the cell does many other steps all
in preparation for the actual cell
division which happens in the mitotic
phase
the interface is divided into three
phases the g1 s and g2 phase during the
gap one phase or the g1 phase the cell
grows and functions normally the g1
phase is marked by increased protein
synthesis and the cell also doubles its
original size now the cell organelle E's
are produced and volume of the cytoplasm
also increases
after the g1 phase the cell can decide
whether it wants to divide or not if the
cell senses that cell division is not
required it passes into the g0 phase
during which the cell remains silent or
if it decides to go on with the cell
division it passes into the next stage
of the interphase known as the S phase
the S phase or synthesis phase is
associated with synthesis of new DNA
from old one the cell doubles the number
of chromosomes this happens due to a
complex process of copying of DNA to
form new DNA from the old one this is
known as transcription if you want to
understand this process in detail make
sure to watch the video on transcription
on our channel link in the description
below the next phase is known as the g2
phase in which the cell continues its
growth and gets ready for cell division
the mitochondria of the cell double and
the cell continues to grow until the
process of division starts so this was
interphase during which the cell grows
and prepares for cell division the next
major stage in the cell cycle is the M
phase which is the actual division phase
M phase or the mitotic phase is divided
into two major phases mitosis and
cytokinesis since both these processes
are very complex and involve a lot of
steps it would be difficult for me to
explain it in a single video so in this
video we will just talk about the
highlights of the M phase whereas I will
make a separate video on mitosis in
which I will explain this process in
much detail so the M phase begins when
the cell has completed the interphase
and is ready for the division the first
part of the M phase is mitosis which is
the step in which the nucleus of the
cell divides into two equal and new
nuclei this happens before the cell
actually divides so for a time after the
mitosis the cell has two nuclei now
briefly talking about mitosis this phase
is divided into four main stages
prophase metaphase anaphase and
telophase you can easily remember these
four phases by the Ray morning P
Matt now during the interphase the DNA
of the cell is present in the nucleus
folded like a long coiled noodle but
this arrangement of DNA is unstable and
may lead to problems during the cell
division so during the prophase the DNA
condenses into X shaped structures known
as chromosomes which can be easily seen
with a microscope this condensation
imparts stability to the DNA the next
phase is the metaphase which is divided
into a prometaphase and an actual
metaphase during the prometaphase the
membrane around the nucleus disappears
and the chromosomes now live free in the
cytoplasm in the actual metaphase the
chromosomes line up at the center or the
equator of the cell which is known as
the equatorial plane one important cell
organelle II that helps this process of
division after this are the centrosomes
and the microtubules projecting from
them together these are known as the
mitotic spindle these microtubules help
to pull the chromosomes of the cell in
two opposite directions we will study in
detail about them in our next video so
after the metaphase the chromosomes are
lined on the equatorial plane and the
microtubules get attached to these
chromosomes in the next phase known as
the anaphase the centrosomes start
pulling the chromosomes apart to the
opposite poles of the cell
since the chromosomes were duplicated in
the S phase each pole of the cell
receives a full set of chromosomes
in the next phase known as the telophase
a membrane forms around each set of
chromosomes to create two new nuclei and
this completes the process of nuclear
division also known as mitosis the next
phase we have is known as cytokinesis
cyto means cell and kindnesses means
movement in this phase the single cell
pinches in the middle to form two
separate daughter cells each containing
a full set of chromosomes within a
nucleus in the first step you can see
that the cell has undergone mitosis next
the cytoplasm pinches in the middle
which leads to formation of two new
daughter cells lastly we have one
important topic left which is the cell
cycle checkpoints cell cycle checkpoints
are control mechanisms which ensure
proper division of the cell if we look
at the interphase we have two important
checkpoints one after the g1 phase known
as the g1/s checkpoint and the second
after the g2 phase known as a g2 M
checkpoint as we discussed during the g1
phase the cell grows and forms new organ
leaves and after the g1 the cell it can
go into the quiescent stage the g0 where
it does not replicate or it can enter
the S phase and proceed with the cell
division whether the cell will go into
the zero phase or the S phase is decided
at the g1/s checkpoint here the RB or
the retinoblastoma gene plays an
important role along with cyclins and
cyclin-dependent kinase --is now if we
look at the interface of the cell in a
straight pathway you can see that the
cell has one set of chromosomes in the
g1 phase which gets duplicated to form
two identical sets in the S phase of the
cell during the g1/s checkpoint the cell
checks whether the DNA of the cell is
suitable for duplication or not if the
cell has damaged DNA which is not
suitable for application the RB gene
remains in an inactive stage and this
cell enters the g0 or the resting phase
whereas if the DNA is alright the RB
gene gets phosphorylated or gets
activated this signals various other
molecules in the pathway and ultimately
the cell enters into the S
pays and proceeds with cell division so
the g1/s checkpoint checks for DNA
damage the next checkpoint is after the
g2 phase known as the g2 M checkpoint as
the S phase is associated with
duplication of the DNA and formation of
a whole new set of chromosomes it is
important to check for any errors in the
newly formed DNA which is done at the g2
M checkpoint if the damaged DNA is found
it undergoes repair or the cell
undergoes automated cell death known as
apoptosis if it is not able to repair
the DNA in time there is one more
important checkpoint that takes place in
the metaphase of the M phase here it is
checked whether the chromosomes are
arranged on the equatorial plate
properly or not if they are arranged
properly the cell signals to enter into
the anaphase during which the
chromosomes are pulled apart this is
done to ensure that both the new cells
get equal an exact copy of the genetic
material so friends this was a brief
overview about the process of cell cycle
and mitosis as I said the process of
mitosis involves lot of details which I
was not able to discuss here for that
make sure to watch the next video on
mitosis for a complete understanding of
cell cycle and mitosis and make sure to
visit med simplified on facebook and
instagram for all the flashcards from
this video guys thank you so much for
watching this video if you found this
video and all the other free educational
videos on this channel helpful you can
now support math simplified on
patreon.com for literally the price of a
coffee cup this will allow me to fund my
work and make more videos like this and
will also unlock some cool patreon only
exclusive content like behind-the-scenes
of these videos upcoming videos early
notifications and exclusive flash cards
and handouts make sure to subscribe us
on youtube for all the upcoming videos
and also make sure to follow us on
Instagram and Facebook for flashcards
notifications and much more